[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight jamal cole is a
political candidate he's running for
congress in the first district of
illinois that covers the south side of
chicago and some of the southern suburbs
in late september jamalcol was walking
in the hyde park neighborhood just yards
from lake michigan
when someone shot him through the arm
in the end cold recovered from his wound
he went back to campaigning and then on
tuesday of this week cole narrowly
escaped being shot a second time some
unknown assailant opened fire with a
rifle right near where cole was standing
just blocks from the university of
chicago so cold dove under a car and
escaped being hit
to be clear these were not assassination
attempts so far as we know against a
local congressional candidate jamal
coldest happens to live in the city of
chicago and living there all of a sudden
is that dangerous
given how dangerous chicago has become
it'd be interesting to know what exactly
the sitting mayor is doing to fight
crime and in fact we do know thanks to a
data breach that revealed city emails we
can answer that question
for example we know that just before
midnight one day last year lori
lightfoot the mayor typed a furious note
to her senior staff she was upset about
crime she just received a shocking
report of offenses in progress evidence
of clear and present danger to the
people of chicago
according to an informant a group of
suspects had been observed playing
basketball outside some of them
reportedly had been seen dunking even
shooting three pointers quote i got a
text from someone who lives on the north
side who reported that dudes were out at
a park playing basketball lightfoot
wrote that one sent me around the bend
thankfully lori lightfoot had a solution
quote here is where i want to be
starting tomorrow you may walk outside
in the immediate proximity of your house
fresh air is important but you may not
act like the city is not in crisis
end quote
according to lori lightfoot the city of
chicago is in crisis
a basketball crisis
meanwhile there's another crisis in
progress people continue to die in huge
numbers in chicago over the past 12
months almost 800 chicagoans have been
murdered according to an analysis by cwb
chicago at least 50 of these killings
this year were committed by criminals
who had been released early on bail they
didn't need to happen
just a few days ago yet another man was
murdered just steps from the university
of chicago
chicago police say it was just before 2
tuesday afternoon the victim a 24 year
old man and recent university of chicago
graduate was killed police say the man
was walking on the sidewalk at ellis and
54th place when the armed offender got
out of a dark colored vehicle demanded
the victim's belongings then shot him in
the chest there were actually two
shootings in hyde park tuesday the first
around noon near 53rd and harper no
injuries reported but congressional
candidate and community activist jamal
cole writing on his facebook page that
he was nearly struck quote today i
thought i was going to die because i saw
blood coming from my neck thinking i was
shot again fortunately it was a scrape
from diving under a car
shot again just a day in the life of a
congressional candidate in the city of
chicago by the way the name of the
murder university of chicago graduate
was dennis jang he was 24 years old he
was killed in an armed robbery
apparently he handed over what he had
but they murdered him anyway in the
middle of the day he is the third
university of chicago student to be
murdered this year
in july a 20 year old called max lewis
was hit in the back of the neck by a
straight bullet as he was sitting on a
subway train
in january a 30 year old graduate
student was killed in a shooting spree
that killed several other people
including a 15 year old girl
the university of chicago is now so
dangerous that the school is offering
free lift rides to students seven days a
week so they don't have to mix with the
local population
that may keep them from getting killed
but it is hardly a solution to the
problem
so what is the solution to the problem
800 people murdered in a year
well no one an authority in chicago
appears to be thinking much about that
lori lightfoot is on the record saying
she believes the core problem is white
racism it's bigoted cops
and for a while some of the more
affluent residents of chicago were
willing to believe that was true in last
last year in september for example
university of chicago students
encouraged by faculty members surrounded
the home of the school's provost they
occupied the street in front of her
house they shut down traffic for an
entire week they demanded disarming and
disbanding the school's police
department
now in one of those twists of irony you
really have to pause to save her those
students are demanding chaperone rides
home because their classmates are
getting murdered because the policies
they advocated for result in death
so this might be a perfect moment for
those kids and the adult nihilists who
pushed them to do what they did to admit
they were completely wrong and learn
something
cops are not the problem
have they conceded that not that we're
aware of nor the city officials who
banned cops from conducting foot chases
admitted that what they did resulted in
the deaths of citizens
we've been watching carefully as far as
we can tell only one person in authority
at the university of chicago understood
what was happening at the time and said
so he's a professor called harold eulig
you look publicly objected to defunding
the police not because he's some kind of
radical but because then as now that is
a completely demented idea that results
in people getting killed so you'll look
said that and for the crime of saying it
he was fired from his job at the chicago
fed
the university of chicago began an
investigation into him for his thought
crime hundreds of economists signed a
petition to have harold eulek removed as
the editor of a major economics journal
what do those views have to do with
economics nothing
but they joined the mob anyway one of
the jackals in that mob by the way was
none other than janet yellen you may
recognize the name because she's now our
treasury secretary
yellen wrote this soviet little
statement at the time quote it would be
appropriate for the university of
chicago which is the publisher of the
journal of political political economy
to review eulog's performance and
suitability to continue as editor
because he opposed getting rid of the
police to this day notably janet yellen
has never retracted that statement or
apologized for joining the mob to hurt
an innocent man for telling the truth
that's fine with her it's fine with her
now
the other activists who targeted harold
yuley have admitted they were wrong no
they haven't
so after the recent shootings near
campus harold eulegg made this request
of the university community quote
if anyone still wants to defund the
police please do me a favor and stay
away from hyde park
but of course that's not what's
happening no one's apologized no one's
learned anything the politicians ruining
the state of illinois in the city of
chicago demand above all that you
worship them like gods as people die
around them
as it happens by the way all this
killing is happening very close to where
former president barack obama is
building a massive unprecedentedly large
shrine to himself known euphemistically
as a presidential library total cost of
this project at least
830 million dollars nearly a billion
dollars to celebrate barack obama just
in case you're wondering what the
definition of malignant narcissism is
how much money is that
for perspective it's nearly half the
entire budget of the chicago police
department to celebrate barack obama who
lives in martha's vineyard and hawaii
not chicago who's worth tens of millions
of dollars not one of which he's given
to help anyone who actually does live in
chicago
we don't mean to pick on obama he's
hardly alone
most people in barack obama's position
which is to say in a position of
authority that might actually help
people prefer to talk about chicago
rather than actually make it better for
the people who live there hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else